alright so hopefully you use some tools
to make that a little bit simpler for
you if we load up the developer tools
here we can see that we've already got a
syntax error and if we go over and click
right here on line 28 and it'll take us
right to where the offending air is you
can see that it actually doesn't
technically take us to the error it
takes us to the line after sometimes
these kinds of tools will get you close
and then you'll have to figure it out
from there so the problem is right here
you see that local user ID calling
negative one doesn't have a comma after
it it just ends and since it was
expecting a comma well JavaScript and
starts a semicolon and that causes
issues so let's go ahead and fix that
one okay so if we insert that comma
there and then reload the page we get
our next syntax error at line 103 and
the air here is that functions expect
parenthesis after them where the
parameters are even if it doesn't take
any parameters it still expects
parenthesis here let's go ahead and add
those in and again reload the page we
get to our next air and this one is way
down online 207 now this is maybe a
little bit harder to see but the problem
is right here this current tick should
have a dot as seen down here rather than
a colon since we use dots to access
member methods and variables okay so now
that we fix this here and then reload we
get to another error on 318 and here we
can see online 318 that we have a comma
here where normally we would use a colon
to specify a member method so if we fix
that and then reload the page we can see
that we don't have any syntax errors
left and those are the only ones that we
put in so you can see that it was a lot
easier to go through the developer tools
and fix these things as necessary as it
pointed it out to us rather than trying
to walk through the code line by line
manually so I hope that shows how useful
it is to have the proper tools on hand